[Music]
have you seen a food color mix in a
glass of water does it mix completely
the moment you put it in the water no
it's a gradual process
and if you observe closely you can see
it slowly spreads in the water similarly
if you take salt crystals and put it in
water you might also notice that the
crystal becomes smaller with time we
usually say that the salt is dissolving
in the water but what happens at a
molecular level
let's see in this video how exactly a
solute dissolves in the solvent
suppose we put salt in water now let's
look at a crystal of salt dissolving in
water a salt crystal is made up of
sodium and chloride ions that are
arranged in a cubic lattice
in it those ions that are at a corner or
an edge are loosely held
and we know that water molecules are
polar in nature with partial positive
charge on the hydrogen atoms and partial
negative charge on the oxygen atom now
as we put the crystal in the water the
water molecules collide with the crystal
until an ion breaks free
since the ions are positively or
negatively charged and the water
molecules are polar more water molecules
are attracted towards that ion and they
cluster around it that is if a
positively charged sodium ion breaks
free the oxygen atom of the water
molecules is attracted towards it and in
the case of negatively charged chloride
ion the hydrogen atoms of the water
molecules are attracted to it
so we see that as water molecules
collide with the crystal a loosely held
ion breaks free
then more water molecules cluster around
the ion stabilizing it by means of ion
dipole interactions the same thing
happens over and over until there
remains no crystal
we say that the solute particles are
dissolving in the solvent forming a
solution this process is called
dissolution but wait something else is
also going on while forming the solution
we saw that ions separate from the
crystal and are stabilized by water
molecules but sometimes the free sodium
and chloride ions collide with the
crystal due to the strong interaction
between the ions and the crystal these
ions become a part of the crystal again
and separate out from the solvent so as
some solute particles are dissolving
into the solution some dissolved solute
particles are also separating from the
solution this process is called
crystallization
therefore in a solution there are two
processes taking place simultaneously
one is a dissolution and the other
crystallization these two processes
together give rise to a dynamic
equilibrium in the solution initially
the rate of dissolution is much larger
than the rate of crystallization this
means there are more solute particles
mixing with the solvent than separating
out but as we add more salt to the
solution the rate of dissolution slows
down and the rate of crystallization
increases a point is reached when the
two rates are equal so if you look at
the beaker there is no visible change we
say that no more salt dissolves in the
solution
but at the molecular level solute
particles are entering and leaving the
solution at equal rates the solution is
in dynamic equilibrium with the
unresolved solute a solution in which no
more solute can be dissolved at a given
temperature and pressure is called a
saturated solution at this point we've
reached the maximum amount of solute
that can be dissolved in the solution at
a given temperature and pressure this
maximum amount of the solute is known as
solubility of the solution
so we see that in a solution to
processes namely dissolution and
crystallization occurs simultaneously as
their rate becomes equal to each other
no more solute is dissolved in the
solution and the solution is called
saturated solution the amount of solute
in the saturated solution is called the
solubility of the solution now notice
that here we mentioned that solubility
depends on the temperature and the
pressure so does it mean that if we
change the temperature or the pressure
of a solvent we will be able to dissolve
more solute
yes we will see how the change in
temperature or pressure office solution
changes its solubility in the upcoming
videos to stay updated and to keep
learning such interesting things
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]